dis-moi julie tout est au point il y
aura pas de problème parfait halal
facteurs alors c'est fait tout a été
livré le gloubiboulga contenait assez de
confiture de fraises et de saucisses de
toulouse
pour sûr il y avait la proportion idéale
parfait et ma classe hachoir a pas de
problème non plus sa tante adélaïde et
la mise tout de suite au réfrigérateur
et je les ai vus à ce moment là elle et
elle était super oui mais une chose m'a
semblé bizarre quand même un peu bizarre
oui tant la glace aux anchois
oui il y avait des reflets bleus dans la
vanille alors vous m'avez fait pas c'est
que casimir adore une petite boîte de
fromage de bleu d'auvergne dans sa glace
à la vanille à bout je ne discute pas
dit il y avait d'autres cadeaux facteurs
euro poursuit donc j'en avais plein et
monsieur du snob un cadeau attendez
attendez
qu'est ce que c'est c'est ça j'y suis
une superbe chambres à air de
motocyclettes dans un grand bocal plein
de crème chantilly sous la halle avec
les immigrés se régaler à d'autant plus
que la chambre air de motocyclettes
c'est celle qu'a le meilleur goût
d'après lui en tout cas merci pas peur
d'avoir à porter tout ça chez lui c'est
mon métier paraît bon bah je crois qu'on
a eu une bonne idée d'envoyer tous les
cadeaux chez casimir heures ça lui fera
une bonne surprise
la seule chose c'est que s'il vient ici
va être déçu qu'on lui fait pas son
anniversaire et ben oui il va arriver on
va faire tout semblant d'avoir
complètement oubliée sur le moment il
sera très triste
il rentrera chez lui dira rien et très
discret et là il découvrira tous nos
cadeaux à sa faut dire qu'il est
vraiment discret ce que dit bonjour le
voilà alors que chacun fasse semblant
d'être très occupé mais je vais
travailler mon courrier sur leboncoin
parfait moi cela me demande
bonjour c'est gentil d'être venu pour
mon anniversaire
parce que aujourd'hui c'est mon
anniversaire
ouais j'espère que françois et julie
n'ont pas oublié un le facteur est là
lui aussi chic ça va peut-être me faire
trois cadeaux attention attention tout
le monde
le voilà qui arrive à benghazi milk
c'est moi casilli oui je fais tu veux me
laisses tes s'il te plaît j'ai un trac
fou tu sais ce que c'est aujourd'hui
bah oui c'est le jour où j'ai le plus de
travail de l'année mais qu'est ce que tu
fais ça fait trois fois que tu mets le
fleuve lui même jouait au même un dollar
ben oui bah oui mais c'était c'est toi
qui me trouves tu comprends je peux pas
concentré paru à la fin
bon un exquis mois françois tu sais ce
qui se passe
dont jean casimir donjon quinze mille
excuses moi je suis très occupé je suis
vraiment très occupé au balo très occupé
mais qu'est ce que tu as à faire
les pillages il faut que je gonfle est
ballot hein
maintenant ils sont déjà gonflé ils sont
déjà gonflé à un homme est sûre malgré
les consignes nniversaire aux gens et
aux jeunes
il faut que je me concentre aulas
bonjour à casimir casimir excuse moi
mais je dois classer toutes ses lettres
mais ce sont des enveloppes blanches
ah oui c'est vrai je suis distraite mais
ne nous distrait pas davantage est alors
laisse moi bon voilà
c'est effrayant n'y a pas un seul qui
n'a pensé à mon anniversaire
1 qu'est ce que je pourrais bien faire
quand j'ai une idée
j'ai une idée selon mercer hausse alors
nniversaire c'est mon anniversaire c'est
mon anniversaire
rien à faire c'est mon anniversaire
c'est mon anniversaire c'est mon
anniversaire mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui je ne les ai jamais vus
travailler comme ça j'ai une autre idée
ma malle magique où est ma malle magique
par la voilà ça va peut-être marché
voilà
en en soit on voit quel travail je coupe
et en os
14 oh
y'a vraiment bien à peine quand je suis
pas triste non plus et j'ai trop envie
de rire
[Musique]
allo ah oui oui il est là à l'instant je
vous le passez casimir cette pensée pour
toi oui hameau pas bonjour tante
adélaïde quoi quoi vient de cadeau pour
mon anniversaire à une chambre air
chantier way une glace aux anchois les
humbles ou bi boulga j'ai en moi sommes
mes amis sont merveilleux merci un merci
ça va être délicieux à 1 c'était
délicieux
pourquoi tout manger il ne reste plus
rien ono